The community of first generation
and low income students at Yale is so tight knit.
I have basically made all of my friends
through this community.
I would say the first generation
college student community at Yale is very vibrant.
I find a lot of support
with other FGLI students
at Yale
I would describe the first generation
community at Yale as just like
people who get it.
They come from similar backgrounds.
They understand your struggles.
Like, you don't have to
explain what you're facing
because they're probably facing it, too.
I was coming 2000 miles from home.
I knew absolutely nobody here,
so it was nice to have some common ground.
I've never felt,
you know, like I didn't belong here.
Anybody who shares that identity knows
that you can go to each other
and feel comfortable sharing
whatever struggles you're going through,
and you're not going to be judged
for that.
I'm still learning to this day about,
like friends I've had all four
years are from a first generation
low income background.
It's a way for me
to sort of connect with people,
and I think that's a great asset
and tool to have in my tool belt.